New Mutants are dangerous.
you're not going anywhere.
this place, takes your greatest fear. And makes you live through it.
Roberto
Sam
Illyana
Dani
Rhaine
We can get out of this. Together.
This place is designed to keep us inside.
he's right. It's magic.
So am I
That was so hot.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie big surprise
we have a Disney plus trailer for new mutants
that seems like it's trying to claim that
they're going to be releasing the movie on
Disney plus so I'll try to explain what's going
on because this was floating around social
media this morning, everyone was freaking
out trying to figure out what was going on.
There's a bunch of comic con trailers coming
this week.
I'll be doing videos for everything, so be
sure to subscribe to get all those videos
I'll do a special comic con giveaway during
all those videos to but just starting at the beginning
If you don't know what's going on a Disney
plus user in Australia recently recorded this
new mutants trailer that they claim was playing
on Disney plus in Australia with some new
scenes in new release date information seemingly
announcing new mutants would be coming to
Disney plus Friday, September 4.
This is that version of the trailer and the
foot is kind of janky because they captured
it with their phone on their TV, but you get
the idea.
So everyone saw this floating around social
this morning and wondered if it was real.
Is it fake did some fans create this and then
posted to read it, or something like that
right after this posted a couple websites
came out claiming the Disney told them that
it's fake, but Disney and Disney people have
been known to lie about stuff like this in
the past everybody remember right after Avengers
infinity war when people wondered with the
title for Avengers endgame was going to be
the Russo's did a really big interview where
they said that the title of Avengers four
has never been said out loud or spoken in
any previous Marvel movies before Q the clips
with the Avengers we can bust arms Georgia
livelong day with Hollywood notice so clearly
at the take all those statements with a grain
of salt reason why directors lie about stuff
like that too is normally to protect the movie
like they did want to giveaway the big title
for Avengers endgame before they were ready
to do.
Sometimes you can understand why they're misleading
about stuff like that but normally you would
just preferred that they say we have no comment
on what the title of the movie is going to
be or some information leaks out you just
preferred that they say no comment instead
of trying to lie and say something completely
different is happening, but number four also
a number of Twitter users pointed out some
things that suggest that the new mutants Disney
plus trailer was real, for instance in Australia
the ratings board that adds the ratings to
movies like is it rated R is rated PG-13 they
have very different logos for their ratings
than they do in other countries like the United
States and in the supposedly new trailer.
There's Australians rating logo localized
for Disney plus in that country, so it's normal
for promos and trailers TV trailers to look
a little bit different in different countries
just based on with the ratings classifications
are then there's the issue of the new footage
playing during this version of the trailer
where did this come from is some of the scenes
are playing are brand-new in some of this
dialogue.
There's a scene of this infrared hospital
monitor with Celia Reyes examining Danny movie
star trying to figure out what her powers
are then there's a scene of demon bear crashing
through a wall that we haven't seen before
and any the other promos it doesn't necessarily
confirm anything, but it does heavily suggest
that new mutants is coming to Disney plus
for an alternate release plan, number three.
The most recent release they plans Disney
announced a while ago were August 28 all over
the world, but that was before all the subsequent
fires flareups in theaters and a lot of places
including the US have had to close down again
so you can even go see a movie.
If you want some places there are some countries
around the world.
Where theaters have already reopened and they'll
stay open and things are totally fine.
So depending on where you live things might
not be that terrible because what Disney is
saying you still to take this Australian trailer
with a grain of salt, but it is possible Disney
has an alternate really weird release plan
for the movie given was happening in the can
announced that at the big comic con panel
later this week new mutants.
Surprisingly, is one of the few movies that
session going to do a big comic con panel
this week.
Of course I'll do a video for whatever they
drop Marvel isn't doing their regular big
hole H panel with any makeup Marvel phase
4 trailer till later this year.
DC is doing the same thing they're skipping
comic con this week to do their own special
comic con event called DC fandom in August.
There will be a lot of big trailers coming
this summer.
So don't worry about that, it is that when
comic con had to cancel the in real life version
of comic con.
Everybody just kind of change their plans
for when the going to release their trailers
the new mutants comic con panel is supposed
to be Thursday afternoon my early theory last
week was that they would announce some special
release plan during that involving video-on-demand
and Disney plus the panels prerecorded it's
knocking to be live, it just that after Christopher
Nolan was forced to reschedule tenants release
date again this past week.
The assumption was that Disney would do the
same thing with all of its movies that were
coming out in August and September like they
have moved lawn they have a couple other big
movies that were supposed to come out around
now that's all going to change because most
theaters in the bigger cities are still close
down.
So number two just talk about larger Disney
plus plans in terms of what Disney itself
is willing to release on Disney plus I think
everyone for the most part just been calling
for new mutants specifically to go video-on-demand
months ago for the whole quarantine lockdown
started in theaters were initially closed
originally, the movie was supposed to come
out in March right at the beginning of the
lock down.
It almost it almost creeped in under the wire
but not quite the movie is totally cursed
six different release dates at this point
I think everyone post all your Avengers means
you thought we would see you trying to sneak
by get yourself released in a movie theater
new mutants, but we did.
We did notice this is actually already done
this with one of their bigger movies this
year.
If you did watch it, or you miss that big
announcement.
It was Artemis fowl, but the reason why Disney
did that was such a big budget movie is mostly
because they thought that it would be a box
office bomb because it got bad early reviews
and then once it actually came on Disney plus
it of course got very bad reviews from everyone
else.
Here's the difference with new mutants, so
Kevin Feige reportedly was very happy with
the version of the movie that they had edited
last year.
The director Josh Boone claimed that after
they finished the most recent cut in Disney
officially took over the release Kevin Feige
in the Disney people didn't ask him to make
any big changes to the movie, so it sounds
like the movie is solid for what it is, and
just to be clear, it was always meant to be
a smaller Marvel horror movie with X-Men characters
set in that universe a while ago Fox reportedly
wanted to ruin the movie, and just make a
bunch of changes to turn into more of a generic
bland teenage superhero movie, but supposedly
once Marvel got their hands on the movie.
They stop all that from happening.
So the work is kind of treating it like its
own small little movie, relatively speaking.
They didn't spend nearly as much money making
it as they did other big traditional MCU movies
like the black widow movie.
That's probably why they're more willing to
release it on Disney plus just because they
don't have as much money to potentially lose
even though Marvel is releasing the movie
technically is not meant to be in MCU movie.
That's why you have the slightly different
Marvel logo rolling at the beginning of all
the trailers is sort of the same situation
therein with Deadpool three like will they
put the Marvel Studios logo at the beginning
of that, even if it's going to be a rated
R movie or is a going to be a different logo,
even if the movie isn't necessarily totally
connected to the MCU.
These are all the big things that you would
hope that they would announce at the big Marvel
phase for comic con panel and Ryan Reynolds
is said that they're trying to figure out
what's going on with Deadpool three, while
also writing the movie.
It will all make sense by the end of the year,
but number one.
What does this mean for the black widow movie
because Marvel still has a giant movie to
release before the end of the year.
Hopefully in the way Kevin Feige talks about
theatrical releases.
It seems like he's kind of forced into a situation
between all the major theater chain owners
in Disney who want to make their money back
on the movie and right now.
Good news is Marvel has not delayed black
widow again is still coming out November at
the end of the year, but Marvel will do a
special big comic con style event later this
year on their own, and just confirm all that
stuff so don't worry too much about it though
also release that first Marvel Eternals trailer,
the falcon winter soldier trailer the Wandavision
trailer maybe some other teasers for Marvel
phase for projects while you wait for all
that you can click here to watch Tom Holland
talk about Spider-Man 3 and the new uncharted
movie that he's making you can click here
to watch Henry cavill Superman build his very
first gaming PC thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe, I'll see you guys tonight!